[Música]
boa noite a a todas ea todos
é uma honra e uma satisfação estar aqui
e poder justamente compartilhar desse
universo de idéias que na realidade a
gente constrói em conjunto e por falar
em construção a gente está hoje aqui pra
falar de matemática importante a
temática da construção do conhecimento
construção do conhecimento essa que nós
percebemos não somente como uma
construção isolado mas uma construção
que se dá através de um caminho um
caminho que se constrói caminhando em
uma construção colaborativa
então na realidade vamos conversar um
pouco sobre um relato um relato de
vivência o relato de experiência sobre a
construção de um conhecimento muito
específico
estou falando aqui então da idéia de
sócio biodiversidade
a idéia de sócio biodiversidade como a
perspectiva de que a nossa
biodiversidade
a nossa diversidade biológica ela é uma
diversidade que é acompanhada de uma
pulsão social e acompanhada de justiça
social injustiça ambiental e por vezes
também de uma construção que é cultural
econômica e política
portanto quando a gente fala em meio
ambiente em diversidade
a gente está falando sempre em sócio
biodiversidade
aí nesse sentido falar em suas
universidades
eu falo um pouco da minha trajetória da
minha construção uma construção que se
deu através do primeiro curso que eu
frequentei foi um curso de graduação em
artes cênicas no curso de cênicas que
comecei três semestres
depois troquei a gente tem essa essa
questão da escolha profissional que uma
escolha complexa mas nada daquilo que a
gente aprende transforma ou vivencia
nada disso é sem sombra de dúvida de
espírito santo
todo conhecimento ele se dá com o
caminho que se faz ao caminhar
então aquilo que eu aprendi em história
da arte aquela sensibilidade em relação
ao universo artístico eu levei sim para
o mundo do direito
não podia deixar de ser diferente
escolhi um dos ramos do direito que é o
direito ambiental é um direito que à
primeira vista parece tão dogmático como
muitos outros mas que a gente pode
através de uma vivência interdisciplinar
uma vivência transdisciplinar são mais
alimentos a esse direito ambiental que
possam justamente contribuir para a
formação daquilo que a gente entende
enquanto a perspectiva ambiental ea
garantia desse direito a um meio
ambiente sadio e equilibrado
e aí nesse sentido claro a gente
contribui para contribuir para a criação
de um programa de pós-graduação e buscar
se transcender a simples dogmática do
direito ambiental e que pudesse fazer
essas conexões necessárias partículas
interdisciplinares
nesse sentido então nós partimos do
pressuposto de que sim existe uma
diversidade biológica
existe uma diversidade social e uma
diversidade por sua vez de direitos
nós como países do sul social e quando
falo em nessa divisão entre norte social
e social é uma divisão justamente
geopolítica
nós estamos falando aqui de uma
interferência econômica e geopolítica
importante ou seja países que continuam
um exercício de reflexão de pós
modernidade ainda dependentes
tecnológicamente que precisam
desenvolver colaborar mais oportunidades
como essa são extremamente importantes
para esse processo de colaboração e que
precisam perceber sim que a sua
construção ela é diferente da construção
dos países do norte social uma
construção que se dá através de um
processo de colaboração mas com a nossa
realidade a nossa realidade de um país
continental como o brasil a nossa
realidade latino americana com sua
diversidade de culturas e como a gente
consegue compreender dentro de uma norma
jurídica essa diversidade como a gente
consegue conectar esses saberes com a
garantia dos direitos dos povos
tradicionais com a garantia dos direitos
das pessoas em relação ao ambiente ao
qual elas com língua e que forma isso
sempre indaguei na trajetória de
pesquisa e na realidade isso se
corrobora com o
as pessoas na américa latina inteira com
a qual tivemos contato de uma forma
interessante para conhecer essa
diversidade riquíssima de conhecimento
em uma visita à corte interamericana de
direitos humanos
você pode notar que ao analisar os
processos ambientais da corte você vê
uma diversidade imensa de significados
nesses processos situações muito
peculiares como indagações sobre a
utilização de agrotóxicos indagações
sobre a questão da instalação de
indústrias de mineração e das ações
sobre recursos hídricos e todas elas na
realidade acabam se conectando
justamente com as pessoas com a justiça
ambiental com a vida que as pessoas
querem realmente viver há uma distinção
de um autor chamado market assim e faz
uma distinção entre emitir iaea nit com
uma vida se apresenta regularmente
através da norma imposta e colocada
pelos homens
n a vida como ela realmente é a vida
dentro da função social a vida em
sociedade a vida em comunidade
nesse sentido então em uma viagem à
costa rica eu pude perceber em uma
conversação da universidade que foi uma
dinâmica muito diferenciada e muito
construtiva onde a gente sai dos muros
de uma simples parece de 15 congresso e
faz algumas visitas dirigidas e como
vocês podem notar aqui por exemplo
aquela frutinha chamada amantino é uma
fruta muito diferente para nós
tem toda uma história de como ela foi
parar na costa rica porque a costa rica
tem essa perspectiva de preservação de
porque também os seus povos tradicionais
falam em agroecologia e também tem os
seus embates com a perspectiva de
preservação
nesse sentido aqui embaixo gente nota
uma pequena propriedade essa propriedade
tem apenas um hectare e meio e ela
produz queijo ou seja o camarada o dono
da propriedade
narra uma história de que certa vez que
o visitou um suíço e aí eles conversaram
bastante início a forma com que você
prepara o queijo
você poderia modificar mas com a
realidade
o tipo de produtos você tem disponível
no local
dentro dessa perspectiva o capital
humano envolvido nisso a construção que
se fez o espaço a garantia do espaço um
espaço que precisa preservar para
continuar subsistindo então pequeno
espaço ele tira o sustentáculo para sua
família
são em torno de oito membros da sua
família e consegue também vender para
fora esse queijo algo muito interessante
que chamou a atenção mesmo em vez dos
aspectos somente turísticos que nós
vemos no lugar mas justamente ir a outro
lugar significa ver a pulsão cultural
desse lugar conhecer a cultura do lugar
conhecer as pessoas à sua
sócio-biodiversidade aqui um pouco dessa
riqueza as fotografias são de minha
autoria um pouco dessas riquezas então
ao circular pelos locais e ver que essa
riqueza biológica também tem a sua
riqueza social e que é garantido espaço
para que essas pessoas possam ter
estratégias de desenvolvimento para que
essas pessoas também possam desenvolver
uma outra perspectiva interessante uma
parceria que nós fizemos com a
universidade federal do mato grosso
então aqui a gente tem uma universidade
federal do mato grosso na sua sede em
barra do garças
então nós vamos conversar um pouco sobre
sócio biodiversidade sobre o direito dos
povos tradicionais enfim colocando essa
relação ea gente pode ver que essa
riqueza natural que existe na
conservação da sociobiodiversidade está
no capital intelectual importante para
isso que a sua riqueza cultural em goiás
velho a gente tem por exemplo uma
riqueza de um capital cultural imenso
brasil que é justamente a obra de cora
coralina a obra poética de cora coralina
e todo o seu potencial de investimento
cultural ao mesmo tempo nós fizemos um
estudo de caso em específico em mato
grosso é muito legal que foi subir uma
quebra de patente amento em uma disputa
que houve em relação à sandálias
havaianas e justamente os povos de uma
determinada tribo xavante em mato grosso
e era justamente sobre a utilização sem
permissão dessa tribo de determinados
desenhos que são utilizados em um ritual
fúnebre específico dessa 30
vejam que interessante né o que está por
trás desse capital nesse capital pode
ser livremente apropriado nós
utilizássemos esse capital cultural para
o desenvolvimento da nossa perspectiva
nacional da nossa perspectiva de
valorização das outras culturas seria
algo como um potencial muito
interessante
ou seja esse capital cultural da
sociobiodiversidade ele tem um valor
extremo a forma com que se vai utilizar
os extratos da fauna e da flora tem um
valor para além do valor econômico e
pode ser utilizado para desenvolver
realmente a nossa indústria nacional e
que não precisa ser somente capitalizado
por indústrias de fora
daí a necessidade da gente reconhecer o
nosso potencial de riqueza ea nossa
forma de programar o futuro em termos de
crescimento em termos de desenvolvimento
de uma comunidade na amazônia também uma
outra parceria com a federal do amazonas
que se chama careiro da várzea e aí a
primeira impacto que nós temos é a
pobreza ou seja sem compreender
literalmente a cultura justamente do
processo de enchente na ilha cheia e de
que as pessoas se acostumam viver nessa
situação e como elas conseguem trazer
uma forma integrada de comunicação via
barcos entre o entre o rio nadando
divisão realmente entre entre o rio
negro solimões ou seja a idéia da
divisão das águas e como eles conseguem
trabalhar e se esse sustentáculo fácil
de um período de cheia então toda a
mobilização social a garantia de
direitos ea perspectiva também de
manutenção da existência dessa população
por fim um grande parceiro nosso já mais
de dez anos que a universidade de
santiago do chile ao site
nós temos um convênio com uma ideia com
o instituto de estudos avançados e
buscamos justamente essa combinação com
outras universidades como a universidade
de temuco e foi a que mais me chamou a
atenção e fica nessa região aqui que a
região nasal câmeras região do sul do
chile e que têm um desenvolvimento muito
interessante em termos de pós graduação
com
o papel do seu indígena que é o povo
mapuche a diferença com o tratamento do
indígena claro que a diferença de
colonização também conta mas a diferença
com o tratamento do povo indígena a
forma com o povo mapuche trabalha
justamente a sua cultura de fundir a sua
cultura trabalha com processos tanto
audiovisuais enfim de resistência de
difusão da sua cultura
você já a valorização que nós temos nos
processos culturais com a percepção
então e garantia de preservação dos
recursos naturais
claro que esses modelos que a gente
apresenta aqui não são modelos absolutos
são modelos que chegam até nós com
possibilidade de refletir que a questão
ambiental hoje é uma questão geopolítica
é uma questão de ecologia política mas é
sem sombra de dúvida uma questão de
cultura uma questão social
portanto não posso pensar a questão
ambiental sem pensarem
socioambientalismo injustiça ambiental
eu não posso pensar a questão ambiental
sem pensarem sócio biodiversidade e por
fim uma escritora indiana muito
importante que a van da chiva ela tem
uma obra chamada monocultura da mente
realmente essa obra foi um momento de
mudança na minha vida em termos de
compreensão dessa obra
basicamente ela diz o seguinte e para
que a gente consiga perceber o todo
dentro de uma área o sistema que é
necessário transcender a uma cultura
somente eu lembro como estudo de caso a
cidade de onde houve investiu
basicamente em uma monocultura é uma
cidade que com o tempo de cresceu em
número de habitantes não pensou em
variar o seu parque industrial não
pensou em investir em outras formas de
desenvolvimento para as suas comunidades
e acabou de certa forma tendo que os
seus jovens saírem dessa cidade comum é
uma realidade da metade sul do do sul na
grande maioria das vezes em velocidade
que eram muito menores algumas décadas
atrás como lajeado estrela cidade que se
desenvolveram muito porque trabalharam
com essa variação com a possibilidade
portanto para fazendo o título de uma
obra de um mundinho unido está em
interpretar martin ryder com dinheiro
diz o seguinte pensar e pensar a
diferença
a nossa possibilidade não pensar somente
estruturas de padronização mas a nossa
possibilidade de pensar estruturas que
nos conduzem a diferença pensar em
inovação pensar em desenvolvimento é
pensar em estratégias diferentes e
colaborativas estratégias que possam
contribuir
o ambiente aqui no certa com as pessoas
que nos cercam e com potencial de cada
um em termos de construção
dentro dessa perspectiva é possível sim
desenvolver com a perspectiva da
diferença é possível uma universidade
mais aberta diferença é possível que nós
recepcionamos pessoas das mais
diferentes classes sociais das mais
diferentes condições porque é justamente
através desse processo que se consolida
uma ideia de justiça social não pensar a
questão ambiental não significa que
pensar somente procedimentos e normas
mas antes mesmo da moda como se deu a
criação dessa norma
como cedeu interferência política e
econômica para a criação dessa norma
essa norma preserva a diferença entre os
povos a igualdade e garante direitos
fundamentais garante a liberdade
individual garante os direitos sociais e
percebe os direitos difusos enquanto
preservação do ambiente sadio e
equilibrado enquanto direito de acesso à
informação sobre os produtos que nós
consumimos
essas reflexões pensa em sinhá universo
do direito
eu tive a oportunidade de ter uma
formação interdisciplinar em uma
graduação mestrado em direito de buscar
um doutorado em ciências humanas o que
de certa forma conseguir fazer essas
conexões
acredito que toda a nossa formação
dentro da nossa estrutura de
conhecimento nada perdido
as diferenças de conhecimentos que nós
aceitamos as pessoas que nós conversamos
todas as pessoas que a gente conhece
contribuir conosco não dentro dessa
perspectiva de formação o pensamento da
diferença essencial lei a base ea idéia
do pensamento complexo
a complexidade percebe é justamente o
que as possibilidades de contingência as
possibilidades de frustração as relações
de confiança que são construídas ea
partir deste link e dessa perspectiva
nós conseguimos construir um
conhecimento que é um caminhão
encaminhar que faz a sua própria trilha
como já dizia o outro dentro desse
processo então é justamente através de
idéias e alternativas de colaboração
como essa do ted x 1 santa maria é que a
gente pode ouvir diferentes
profissionais consegue conectar essas
idéias todas e todos nós saímos daqui
certa forma maiores com um crescimento
maior
ou pelo menos com determinadas redes e
possibilidades de colaboração e nos faça
evoluir e nos façam crescer nesse
sentido também penso que a nossa
sistemática de educação deve mudar a
sistemática de educação deve permitir
justamente o que a gente consiga
colaborar mais o professor visto como um
facilitador
aquele que consegue certa forma alcançar
e motivar e conseguem certa forma
provocar determinadas colaborações
provocar determinadas em patins e
colaborações que são necessários para o
nosso desenvolvimento
eu creio que todos aqui devem lembrar de
uma forma ou de outra em um professor
que o motivo de uma frase que o motivo
ou de um sentimento que o pessoal olha
eu posso pesquisar dessa forma eu posso
buscar uma outra alternativa
eu posso acrescentar para aquele colega
para a pessoa que me cercam
não dê nada basta o conhecimento nós
queremos simplesmente meros reprodutores
e na realidade esse conhecimento ele não
teria esse valor agregado essa força que
o conhecimento pode ter que é justamente
nessa emancipação um outro autor que eu
gosto muito já havia citado que o
amartya sen
ele fala na idéia de desenvolvimento
como liberdade nenhum desenvolvimento
pode aprisionar todo o desenvolvimento
tem que ser voltado ao que a liberdade
emancipação que o desenvolvimento só
produz acúmulo de riqueza para um grupo
não é desenvolvimento que não produziu
emancipação de um povo é uma situação de
uma comunidade e principalmente mais do
que uma situação produzir a autonomia
educar e educar para a diferença na
percepção das diferenças na complexidade
que nos cerca e educar também educar
para a autonomia autonomia que é
justamente a possibilidade que nós temos
de sermos empreendedores de produzirmos
inovação
essa inovação está e nata justamente
nessa perspectiva esse conteúdo que eu
apresentei hoje é um exemplo é
específico sobre como pensar perspectiva
ambiental de uma forma diferente um
pensar que a perspectiva ambiental têm
também influência política tem também a
confiança econômica e também influência
cultural talvez a forma plena com que eu
aprendi na educação básica que a questão
ambiental era somente a erosão do solo
poluição do ar e da água
as minhas percepções foram mudando ao
longo do tempo
a questão ambiental é muito mais que
isso a questão ambiental é um elemento
crítico a questão ambiental é o elemento
humano ele mandou do somatório de
cultura tudo certo e também dentro de
uma perspectiva de que pensar essa
diferença é ser humano é justamente a
nossa propositura técnica será
atravessada pelo elemento humano que nós
seríamos unicamente reprodução de
técnica é uma técnica isolada sem a
reflexão crítica e sim a percepção desse
elemento humano foi um prazer uma honra
estar aqui podendo vir a todos e também
poder contar um pouco dessa experiência
de pesquisa eu acho que é justamente a
vantagem nossa é poder trocar
experiências de pesquisa e poder
contribuir para uma colaboração muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]